[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight if you can remember that far
back
Democrats formally began impeachment
proceedings against President Trump on
September 24th of this year today nearly
two months later they held their first
public hearing CNN went wall-to-wall
with it all day under strict
instructions from their reclusive dwarf
king to squeeze every last drop of
partisan drama for the proceedings if
you get stuck in an airport and happen
to catch some of it you can testify to
how pointless and tiresome the whole
thing was if nothing else it made you
realize that Democrats really have no
master plan for impeachment whatever you
may suspect they clearly haven't thought
it through they're making it up as they
go along as most people in DC are and in
the end impeachment almost certainly
will hurt them the whole premise is just
too dumb not to hurt them but in the
meantime here's the good news we did
solve at least one nagging mystery today
Trump's crime has never been clear
exactly what Democrats believe is the
impeachable offense here but now we know
it's this wouldn't it actually be
wonderful if we could get along with
Russia we get along with Russia we go
out together with others and we knock
the hell out of Isis wouldn't that be
great
so that was August of 2006 T wouldn't it
be great if we got along with Russia it
turns out that voters agreed with that
view they elected Donald Trump president
just three months after he said that but
permanent Washington was appalled
scandalized really getting along with
Russia isn't simply considered an
alternative view here it's a crime
listen a State Department veteran George
Kent one of the witnesses who testified
today explains that conflict with Russia
is the entire point of American foreign
policy the United States has very clear
national interests at stake in Ukraine
Ukraine success is very much in our
national interest in the way we have
defined our national interest broadly in
Europe for the past 75 years our
strategic aim
the entirety of my foreign service
career is not possible without a Ukraine
whole free and at peace including Crimea
and the Donbass territories currently
occupied by Russia okay you need to get
a pen this is getting complex but it's
important the territorial integrity of
Ukraine is essential to America's
national interest now our own borders
mean nothing of course defending them is
racist and it's immoral everyone in
Washington knows that and they'll remind
you of it if you think otherwise but
Ukraine's borders and by the way the
borders of Crimea and Donbass wherever
those places might be those are vitally
important matters and have been George
Kent tells us for 75 years or as he puts
it for the entirety of my foreign
service career so back off Donald Trump
with your wild ideas about changing
things simply because the world is
totally different now and voters want to
move on moving on isn't allowed here
change is prohibited career bureaucrat
William Taylor agreed Ukraine is a
strategic partner of the United States
important for the security of our
country as well as Europe Ukraine is on
the front line of in the conflict with a
newly aggressive Russia okay for God's
sake America listen to what this man is
saying and we're quoting Ukraine is on
the front line in a conflict with a
newly aggressive Russia so we need
Ukraine like a drowning man needs a life
ring or more precisely like an alcoholic
needs a drink we've been doing it this
way for so long that we are addicted to
many careers depend upon keeping our
assumptions exactly where they were in
the fall of 1977 when fighting the
Soviet menace consumed the lion's share
of our federal budget by the way if we
don't they could invade Afghanistan
which is strategically essential as you
know so here in Washington that's what
we're doing a real fear is that the rest
of America what some point discovered
that the Soviet Union no longer exists
we're afraid to learn that Russia's
economy is now the size of Italy that
their military budget is 1/10 of ours
that their only aircraft carrier needs
to be
around the ocean because it's broken
that their best scientists and engineers
have moved to New Jersey leaving them
unable to build a working escalator that
if we're really being honest here Russia
poses no threat to the United States at
all
Washington doesn't want you to know that
which is why William Taylor and George
Kent and many of their friends spent all
day insisting that Russia remains a
moral threat to our country ultimately
Ukraine is on a path to become a full
security partner of the United States
within NATO US and NATO Allied trainers
develop the skills of Ukrainian units at
Yahveh reef near the Polish border and
elsewhere we and NATO began to provide
military assistance to Ukraine's Armed
Forces in the form of training advise
military equipment and weapons man feel
better rest easy America NATO is
providing critical military assistance
to our Keala Ukraine in a struggle
against Leonid Brezhnev and the Red Army
we're fighting them in Korea why so we
don't have to fight them in Cleveland
that's what they're telling you that's
what they're demanding that you believe
drunk by the way disagrees with that
he's saying things like this if you look
at the Ukraine we're the ones always
fighting on the Ukraine I never hear any
other countries even mention Ukraine is
very far away from us how come the
country's near the Ukraine surrounding
you great how comes they're not opening
up and they're not at least protesting I
never hear anything from anybody except
the United States what I'm saying is
NATO is absolutely NATO is is obsolete
and it's extremely expensive to the
United States disproportionately so
Ukraine is very far away from us
that could be Trump's campaign slogan
fact let's hope it is Trump's campaign
slogan now it's not a sentence it's
gonna get you 800 on the SAT obviously
but there is a kind of simple brilliance
to it it implies a question that
official Washington cannot answer and
the question is this why exactly we
doing things this way how does it help
America for daring to ask that question
which is the only question that matters
ever
they are impeaching him listen to Adam
Schiff admit
while the founders did not intend that
impeachment be employed for mere
differences over policy
they also made impeachment a
constitutional process that the Congress
must utilize as necessary you want to
know what the left is up to it's not
hard actually to divine what they're up
to
there's a code write this down listen
carefully to what they deny that is
always the real answer so you're not
supposed to impeach a president over
policy differences that says Adam Schiff
and he's right about that and yet that
is exactly indeed precisely what they
are doing